最近
寒くないですかこれでジャズ見せそうです
2シリーズでております内容三反田さんま23ポッパロ抱くだろう
バサー老舗へも行きライオントラさんコア塞ぎさん詐欺さんハリネズミハリネズミ
で最後撮影がいるわけでございますどこに置こうバッファロー buffalo 多
すぎなんだよなぁこれが僕が今持ってるすべてですこれでいいんですね
はぐれてまーす
北にも分からないなぜなぜしゃくれているのかよく分からないフィギュアが今までに
シリーズでたんですけども
今回なんと
朝鮮に乗ったのでしょうか第三が起きました
そろそろいいんじゃない第3弾まで来るとってことはすごい粋なのかな間だけ
ガチャガチャでこのよくわかんないのか第3弾までくるってことは
ウェディング金っていう設置がありますねこれでちょっと者くれるプロジェット旋風が
来てる違うぞというわけでまだの第3弾買ってきたカプセル冬涼しげな色なんですけど
あのボケが入った時はめっちゃ怒ってましたまたタブで大事なだけダメ
や売り切れてて動いて売ってなかったみたいなことが結構あったんですけど山田どこっ
てたんで欲しい方は第3弾だらまだ間に合う気がしますまぁちょっと大産卵まで来て
ちょっと飽きちゃったけどん
とは言えませんなここどこだと言う音等の艶増えるって考えるととてもいいことなん
じゃないかとか思ってむっちゃ買ったのでちょっと開けていこうと思います最低限
ちょっと上げていきましょうか
まずは1個目バッファロー3体頭のとか結構国内炭でカーぶりは本当に勘弁して欲しい
ところではあるが1個目を開けてきますはかるかる
めっちゃ軽いぞいきますはい
グッ
入ってういって食べてください
あっは子犬3マンはんですね
まあ相変わらずの尺度ですねすぎワーワーちょっと予想せなかったら今回何であるか
ちょっと見ていきましょうか
てくれプラネット3絶対シロクマ号たりな白くもうあたりのと中にもいる
これはワーナー金狼さんだ新しいも入れなペンギン
人となりこれ誰大河津個人的にはやっぱシロクマが一番欲しいですね今回ちょっとアレ
でね冬というか寒い地方にいる動物たちがピックアップされてますねまぁオオカミが出
てまぁ良しとしますおこっからちょっと狼が被っても助けないところありますねだ次
いきますオーナーちょっと微妙の多さだなこれは
はい
えっここをシェイプセーブせぷたーい
うーん
わっはっは
くらーざラスですねわぁダンスやかっけー
イケメンならそうめんキッチナーこれ本当ですね
優れてる以外はすごいリアルなんですよねいい流れが来ているどんどん行きましょう
やっぱりこれいきまちょっと白いハイアー
早っだここでまたこの頭てお腹しますともう花瓶2代目です6種類あって肋骨から去っ
てないんでこの時点で全するい制覇することはなくなりました
まあできればそろって畑を当てたいところではあるて次いきます頭だけほんとにようだ
いきますよ
はいええええええええ
はい
悪ふざけんかわいいですねってやばい頭が続いてます新しいです
骨だけになる
かわいいですじゃあやばいやばいにもんとこ4つ開けてに守備しか出てないっていう
じゃ歯医者でちょっとさっきが不安ですね
タブか無事たくないんだよいきます
はいうん風+んだに山代目は萎えるわはずらしい
3体目ですこれどう積んだよねあーくんなよ
かぶったですね oe ちゃん触れろよな
れろれろギャメロって喧嘩すん
いやーこの頭はヤバイですよネカマっちばき屋
な目が印象的です待っておりなっているどう撮ってんだこれね待って5個分けて二種類
しか出てないぞ
あーこれでこれはもうらストイックにかけるしかないですよねで裏そ1個思い名これで
白いカバーが出ればもう満足
とりあえずシロクマされてれば僕はもセーフだと思ってるんでちょっと期待して開けて
みようと思います頼む
デレないッ
たーっつまり久保ず理論とかけています
すって
2きたあっえっえっ
するローザとっ
new があった宿れたよなぁ弾きシロクマやっと出ました
かわいいです
米は割れてねこの完全に割れてる完全に割れてるすげーやっぱりこいつらちゃんねらー
だったらつーわけで最後何度か奇跡的にシロクマは出ることができました
いやーよかったんですけど6種類デートを張って6個買ったんですよ
その結果これでしょたったの3する必要よこれマジでまた買いシャクシャク
シャクシャク
n 誰だ
ピザや言語国不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
穴な事を喋った
をよ前6個買って3種類しか出てないのか
5分 cocco 洗いすぎて顎がしゃくれてまうわー
は7まあそんな悲しい関数になってお前の場合にはこんなにも沢山の方がいる
[音楽]
俺は陸奥その1人さ楽しかった
そう全部当たんなくてもいいじゃないか俺たちとなく
ぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜー教え
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
バッハ